on peut se rendre maintenant en ontario
où d'oxford je le disais vient de
remporter un deuxième mandat majoritaire
yasmine vous êtes donc au rassemblement
les troupes de doc ford 7 victoires
conservatrices et peut-être pas une
surprise qui laissait son ampleur
souvenez vous en 2018 les ontariens
avaient massivement voté contre kathleen
wynne et contre 15 ans de règne libéral
cette année ils ont voté massivement
pour doc celle de chrome semble être en
bonne posture pour gagner plus de sièges
qu'en 2018 et plus de sièges aussi qu'à
la dissolution de l'assemblée
législative quand il avait 67 sièges en
ce moment les
progressistes-conservateurs ont
80 une construction qui sont en avance
et en ontario le chiffre magique pour
une majorité c'est 63 sièges sur 124
donc ça va bien et si on regarde la
carte là c'est vraiment raide ma les
bleus auxquels on a le droit dans le
grand toronto
région stratégique où les conservateurs
semblent avoir réussi à reprendre que le
comté de brant pourtant quand comptez
néo démocrates mais aussi dans le
est de la province ils ont réussi une
percée à windsor t comme si une
circonscription
leur candidat un judas oui il ya
remporté son siège et c'est le premier
conservateur à réussir à percer en 93
ans dans cette région donc une soirée de
victoire pour les conservateurs puis on
sent ici les militants sont au beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé doc feuilles qui a
regardé la soirée électorale chez lui et
to be com et on sait qu'il est en route
pour venir ici et s'adresser le
finalement
beaucoup d'ambiance selon vous êtes sans
doute une autre ambiance ailleurs parce
que la bataille pendant toute cette
campagne c'était vraiment pour la
deuxième place c'est donc le npd qui
remporte la mise la soirée est plus
difficile pour les libéraux leur chef a
été défait
voilà et le npd a quand même réussi à
maintenir le statut d'opposition
officielle à queen's park ils ont loué
des faits qu'en 2018 et puis ils ont
quitté queen's park avec 3 38 sièges et
cette fois ci bien
bhl être en mesure d'aller en chercher
maintenant du côté libéral beaucoup plus
difficile on semble avoir seulement neuf
sièges d'acquis après la déconfiture de
2006 quand il avait remporté sept sièges
et du côté libéral
[Applaudissements]
de ron bourgeois jetons quel sera
l'avenir d'andré horvat au npd et celui
de siemens indiqué au parti libéral il
dhr à voir mais pour l'instant ici
d'oxford n'est pas très loin et puis
c'est vraiment on voit ce qu'on est en
ce moment
l'ambiance de fête ses 120 t on a du mal
à vous entendre parfois mais dont vous
attendez vous suivez ces résultats et
aussi le discours de drogue j'imagine je
trouve un peu plus tard merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci